a finale that negated nine seasons of
storytelling a superhero undone by beer
the most dramatic haircut ever seen on
teen tv even the most celebrated shows
can miss the mark but these disastrous
episodes nearly tanked their entire
series
after a critically acclaimed debut
season friday night lights kicked off
with season two with an underwhelming
premiere when landry wax tires creepy
attacker with a pipe and dumps his body
in a river a respectable show depicting
an otherwise nuanced and realistic
depiction of texas life turned into an
over-the-top melodrama for two of its
characters actors jesse plemons and
adrian paliki do a decent enough job
with the material but this bizarre
subplot belongs in another show if we
wanted to see this kind of death and a
slowly unraveling cover-up we would have
tuned into a soap opera the killing of
the random stalker guy screamed network
interference and distracted viewers from
the other parts of the story who cares
that coach taylor has to end his
paternity leave or that julie feels
hemmed in by her first serious
relationship when there's a dead body in
the river friday night lights would
eventually resolve the subplot with
relatively little consequence and go on
to earn its place in our hearts but
season 2 opener last days of summer
remains its low point
in retrospect battlestar galactica would
have been even better if it hadn't
committed to the old model of the 22
episode season has intended to have a
couple of random filler episodes each
year no episode is more skippable than
season two's black market which seems
like a classic case of writers trying to
fit a square peg into a round hole the
episode is about an investigation into
an off-book black market that's
supposedly impossible to corral when
commander fisk is found dead captain
apollo begins digging and discovers that
fisk was involved in the black market
after nearly 30 episodes of the show we
learned that apollo has a long lost love
from back home that he's never once
mentioned and a relationship with a sex
worker that he regularly sees in the
fleet despite his tension with starbuck
at the end of the episode after killing
a couple of gangsters he allows the rest
of the villains to keep doing their
black market thing so long as they stop
killing ship commanders and trafficking
humans so you're still in business
for now
it's a thoroughly nonsensical episode
one so bad that battlestar galactica had
to pull out all the stops with a
brilliant season-ending time jump on new
caprica to make us forget it
stranger things is lucky that it came
out in the era of streaming if fans had
been forced to wait an entire week after
the season 2 episode the lost sister
they might have revolted every season of
stranger things has replicated the
formula of the first with varying
degrees of success co-creators matt and
ross duffer are pros at stretching a
feature film-worthy adventure into eight
or nine hours of television by episode 7
we're usually hurtling towards some big
confrontation but the lost sister halted
that momentum to follow 11 on a
standalone sidequest to chicago to
reconnect with another experiment tea
from her past
sister
sister
she ends up with slightly enhanced
powers and a cool new goth vibe but not
much else of relevance happens it's a
complete wrench in what was a well-oiled
binge-worthy machine of a show in a
world where stranger things aired weekly
on cable fans would have spent seven
long days seething luckily all they had
to do was take a deep breath and let
netflix play episode 8 automatically
nbc's er was once the epitome of
prestige network drama it was a serious
gripping portrayal of the passionate
people saving lives in a chicago
emergency room while it dabbled in the
occasional raiding stunt with plot lines
involving escaped convicts serial
killers or george clooney rescuing a kid
trapped in a storm drain it generally
aimed for a realistic grounded sense
what life working in a hospital would be
like as the years went on the cast
changed and the writers needed to up the
ante in the season 10 episode free fall
dr romano is crushed by a falling
helicopter in an impossibly slow scene
with hilariously bad cgi even for 2003.
this came after dr romano had an arm cut
off by a helicopter rotor in the
previous season er would run for 15
seasons in total so freefall didn't
outright ruin it however the helicopter
sequence did make the show much more
difficult to take seriously from that
point on
in truth any episode from community
season 4 would be right at home on this
list creator dan harmon got forced out
by nbc after season 3 but the show
continued for an entire season before he
got reinstated it retained most of the
writing staff but they took the show in
a lighter safer direction and it was
terrible intro to felt surrogacy an
episode that utilized puppets of the
main cast felt like a pale imitation of
the claymation episode from season 2
abed's uncontrollable christmas another
low point was heroic origins in which
abed discovers the group had all crossed
paths before meeting at greendale
essentially retconning the pilot episode
these aren't plot holes avid this is my
life but this kind of connection only
makes our origin story more compelling
the lowest low point was economics of
marine biology the poorest rated
community episode on imdb with a score
of just 6.7 it centers around the
college getting ready to woo a potential
new student with lots of money den of
geek observed that this episode's plot
line was incredibly formulaic which
makes for very bland television
even by the standards of lost's
notoriously convoluted season 3 stranger
in a strange land might be the most
inconsequential pointless episode of the
show some mildly gripping nonsense with
the others happens on the island while
the flashbacks clue viewers in on a
mystery nobody was wondering about what
is the meaning behind jack's terrible
tattoos in a painfully pointless series
of events jack has a brief fling with a
mysterious tattoo artist in thailand and
then gets beaten up in the present we
learn that his ink translates to he
walks amongst us
but he is not one of us
your tattoos
that's what they say the wording is
parallel to how the bible describes
jesus as in the world but not of the
world however the writers leave it
unclear as to whether the tattoo has a
similarly spiritual meaning or if the
tattoo artist just marked jack as a
tourist either way stranger in a strange
land is an hour that even the biggest
loss fans wanted back
after nine years how i met your mother
delivered a polarizing finale while it
was clear that future ted telling a
rambling story to his children was just
a fun framework for the show it didn't
mean that fans weren't invested in the
resolution of ted and tracy's
relationship the showrunners
underestimated how much ire the finale
would generate by killing off the mother
minutes after she and ted finally meet
only to pawn future ted off on the still
magically single robin the point of the
story is that is that you totally
totally totally have the hots for aunt
robin whether or not it was planned all
along it turned what should have been a
perfect landing from a beloved show into
a bewildering reframing of the entire
story how i met your mother hasn't
enjoyed the resurgence in popularity
that other staples like friends and the
office have on streaming services but
the hulu spin-off how i met your father
proves that its legacy nonetheless
survived the hit
even the most beloved shows have
episodes that fans always tend to skip
and the great divide is the ultimate
proof of that this much derided episode
of avatar the last airbender suffers
from being an entirely parenthetical
entry with no relevance to any serial
plot as two bickering clans argue about
how to cross a vast canyon these tribes
were never featured in the main story
before this episode and they were never
seen again making the whole plot line a
waste of time for both the showrunners
and viewers as if to try and justify the
episode's existence our heroes get
caught up in this petty drama and start
acting out of character in ways that
shoehorn moral lessons into a show
that's otherwise known for restraint and
subtlety aang resorts to deception while
katara and saka each sympathize with a
separate tribe the great divide seems
like it was written by someone who
hadn't seen the rest of the show and the
fans continue to unite in critiquing it
beloved as it is buffy the vampire
slayer isn't a show famed for its
consistency it often relied on monster
of the week style episodes that were
self-contained and not connected to each
season's big bad meaning it would
usually have a few duds per year season
4's beer bad comes across more like an
after-school special about the dangers
of alcohol than a fun installment of the
classic urban fantasy series an
enchanted beer causes buffy to devolve
into a primal urge based version of
herself
want more singing
want more beer in her enchantedly
drunken state buffy starts to draw cave
paintings on her dorm room wall this is
all supposedly meant to illustrate how
upset buffy is about being dumped by
some jerk the story ends abruptly
without any consequences for the
bartender that drugged a bunch of
teenagers with magic beer beer bad is
bad tv pure and simple
the first season of parks and recreation
is nothing like the rest of the show the
main character amy poehler's leslie
knope was essentially an even more
boorish and awkward version of michael
scott from the office which it was
clearly trying to imitate the show had
only a distant echo of the earnestness
it would come to be known for and if it
had been cancelled before season two
nobody would have batted an eyelid rock
show the final episode of season one
veered into slapstick territory mark
gets rejected by a very angry anne then
makes a drunken attempt to kiss leslie
before falling into a pit it's a weird
and cringe-worthy end to a season that
hits all the wrong notes and could
easily have been the last straw for the
series nbc of course gave it another
shot and the subsequent six seasons will
live in the hearts of viewers forever
most millennials remember felicity a
show about the college life of carrie
russell's curly haired eponymous
character they also likely remember that
in the season 2 episode of the list
felicity cut her famous hair on a whim
causing shock and outrage in equal
measure felicity's famous locks were
part of her character and when she said
goodbye to them some fans said goodbye
to the show seeing it as the end of a
chapter what got lost in the reaction to
felicity's pixie cut is that a sudden
dramatic haircut is a pretty reasonable
reaction to a breakup like the one she
has with ben in the same episode
thankfully felicity survived the
dramatic haircut and went on to detail
all four years of our heroine's college
experience the final season would end
with a multi-episode time travel arc
that's far more unique and memorable
than the close-up snipping of some
scissors
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]